je suis et maurice bernier je devrai
saint-aubert
je suis prêt de se faire un pari j'ai 63
ans j'ai mis à plat sur mille petits
accords d'inclusion je tenais maladies
dégénératives musculaires
maintenant je ne marche plus depuis
l'automne prochain les ruches peut plus
sortir la fine silhouette la seconde
fois seulement
je vois un look jean port joli logo mon
tour j'ai fait ma manouche et accusé des
mêmes faits ici le cheval comme abobo ce
que j'ai pu j'ai plus d'énergie du trou
difficile de l après j'avais une case
intestins qui communient que j'ai pas
suivi de traitement ne veut pas de
traitement c'est ma délivrance est
peut-être le cry qui vous allez plus
vite qu'elle met la digue le fait qu'à
la fin ça va être la mairie pour moi la
manche est vraiment une délivrance
gk